欢迎回到列表解析的课程
第二部分要讲的是
一个可以合并两个列表的函数 zip （拉链）
下面是 zip 的签名
zip 的类型是从 a 的列表到 b 的列表 到 (a,b) 对的列表
下面是一个合并两个列表的例子
从中可以看出为什么这个函数称为 zip 它接收两个列表
从中各取一个值 合成一对
[a,b,c] 和 [1,2,3,4] 的 zip 结果是
[(a,1), (b,2), (c,3)]
一旦其中一个列表的值用尽
zip 函数就停止 右侧列表有四个元素
左侧列表只有三个元素 结果列表
有三个元素 正如之前提到过的
我认为 zip 函数的签名
如果没有被柯里化（curried）会好一点
从 a 的列表与 b 的列表的一对
到 (a,b) 对的列表
但 zip 在 Haskell 标准库中是这么定义的
使用 zip 可以定义下列函数
给定一个列表 返回相邻两个元素对组成的列表
在看实现之前 让我们先看一个例子
我认为看了例子后 实现也就很简单了
想要做的是 给定列表 [1, 2, 3, 4] 要创建一个元素对的链条 像一个像滑动窗口一样 [(1, 2), (2, 3), (3, 4)]
可以看到相邻的两个元素被链到了一起 (1, 2) (2, 3) 之后是 (2, 3), (3, 4)
其实现是一个使用 zip 的很好的例子
要做的是取这个列表 [1, 2, 3, 4]
再取这个列表的 tail
[2, 3, 4] 再两个列表 zip 到一起
结果就是 因为第一个列表是 [1, 2, 3, 4]
第二个列表是 [2, 3, 4] zip 到一起就是 (2, 3)
之后下一个 zip 到一起 抱歉前一个应该是 (1, 2)
下一个是 (2, 3) 再下一个是 (3, 4)
如果画图表示的话
首先是原来的列表 接着去掉第一个元素
其余元素向前移一位 接下来把两个列表 zip 到一起
最终结果就会如此
这是另一个函数 用 pairs 函数检查列表是否排好了序
要做的是取列表中的相邻元素对
也就是许多 (x, y) 对
我们检查第一个元素是否比第二个元素小
如果每一个相邻对中 第一个都比第二个小 列表就是有序的
这种检查有序的方法十分简洁 看一些例子
列表 [1, 2, 3, 4] 是有序的吗 的确如此
因为 (1, 2) 中 1 小于 2 下一个元素对是 (2, 3)
2 同样小于 3 最后一个元素对是 (3, 4)
3 小于 4 因此整个列表有序
列表 [1, 3, 2, 4] 是有序的吗
不 因为元素对列表中的第二对
(3, 2) 中 3 比 2 大 因此会返回假
使用 zip 还可以定义列表中元素的位置
之前提到 列表中没有位置
在数组中可以用下标索引 但列表中不行 只能从左向右访问元素
比如取 head 接着是 tail 的 head 再接下来是 tail 的 tail 的 head 等等
但有时给列表中的元素指定位置会方便些
这种操作很常见 实现的方法就是 zip
要做的是 取一个列表 xs
再取一个 0 到 n 的列表
其中 n 是列表的长度
但实现上可以用从 0 开始的无限长的列表
接下来只需要把列表和位置 zip 起来就可以了
这个 positions 的例子中 要获得所有 0 的位置
比如这里 这里还有这里 所做的是
首先将所有元素和位置 zip 起来 接下来只过滤留下那些
要寻找的元素
这里我们感兴趣的是 0 的位置
整个过程分为两步 第一步将所有元素和位置组成对
第二步 过滤 只保留我们需要的元素
Haskell 中字符串 String 不过是字符（Character/Char）列表的语法糖而已
这也意味着字符串上也可以使用列表解析
比如字符串 abc 不过是字符 a b 和 c 组成的列表 因此所有列表操作
包括解析 map 和 filter foldr 等所有列表操作都可以用在字符串上
比如字符串 abcde 的长度是 5
为何如此 因为这个字符串只不过是 5 个字符的列表
因此可以使用列表的长度函数 length 要取字符串的前三个字符
可以使用 take 3 结果是 abc
用同样的方式可以将一个字符串和列表 zip 到一起
比如将字符串 abc 和列表 [1, 2, 3, 4] zip 到一起 就得到了一个列表
元素是 (a, 1) (b, 2) 和 (c, 3) 这样的对子
很多语言中 是通过让 String 实现可遍历（Iterable）或可枚举（ Enumerator）来做到这一点的 但在 Haskell 中
字符串 String 和列表相比 没有那么多特殊之处
仅仅被定义为字符的列表
差异仅仅是多了一种字面值（literal）的写法
就好比列表的写法一样 正如之前所说的
只是 (1:(2:(3:(4:[])))) 的简略写法而已
下面是一个统计字符串中小写字母数的例子
首先给我字符串 xs 中的所有字符 x
将小写的字符过滤出来
再计算长度
比如要计算字符串 “Haskell” 中的小写字母数 可以得到 6
2 4 6 然后第一个字母是大写的
好了 希望你稍微理解一点列表解析 zip
以及字符串仅仅是字符列表
练习中用到它们的机会很多 那么下周见
再见 Hacking 愉快